has everyone but shawn played this at
least once we found little goats yeah i
remember that okay that's the farm house
then the asylum
is uh
you've done this on them too nope i
haven't done it i haven't done it okay
okay this one's new
the inn is new the town is new literally
only done the farmhouse so the town is
the newest map
the n is probably the scariest map the
first two are probably the simplest to
learn the mechanics scary
i gotta can't be zara i'll leave player
collisions off so we don't hate each
other more than we already do that
doesn't sound fun i'll pick it up quick
super easy you gotta you gotta find
what's the animal what's what is it
spooders
spooders uh yeah actually so the
mechanic changes a little bit yes it is
but it's it's different so we're not
burning goats this time we're doing
something else
yeah goats is only the first map it
changes after that okay then i can't
explain it to you good luck
oh
lord
[Music]
[Music]
a spirited group of friends
and we're almost friends why don't we do
the backstory
oh my god mark's laughing is real laughs
i haven't heard it in so long yeah
how embarrassing i can't believe you let
it out
[Laughter]
as a former cult member oh my god how
long is this loyal friends
it's almost done this is the rich
backstory and lore of this world we're
about to drop into what do you mean how
long it is
how could you belittle it like this
animated video
waiting for
yeah haven't i played this before
before
i forget what the collectibles are i
think there's a collector i'm in
i'm going i'm in baby
all right well found a medkit
great all right i've not played this map
in a while so what are you going to say
before we go in definitely always never
somewhere along the line if you guys
care to find something
to collect
i think i keep clicking and
they're flowers okay there's flowers
they're little lotus flowers kind of
battery
guys i found a zen garden
blood
daikon radishes found booze bro in this
having one place that we take things
there's different ritual altars around
the map and we have to find things that
have that symbol and take them to their
appropriate altar to get rid of them uh
pool table count as one cool eggs must
be placed at this shrine
how do you hear creeks i hear crates i'm
scared i'm coming back this is one of
the altars where we'll be sacrificing
things
uh-huh and if you follow me i've already
lost one of you if one of you at least
follows me this way
huh
guys i found some lore
this is the uh oh you want to read the
lord
everything is ready i've set up the last
shrine
mum and dad tried to interfere so i had
to stop them i can't let anything come
between me and zazzle now as a zazzle
he's almost here i can feel him
the others may have failed but this time
i made the ritual translations from the
old texts myself they're accurate
besides i have the strength to control
him with capital h
i thought about a career voice right
here sean these pools are very important
this and this this bottle that i picked
up if you uh
does it hold e on either of these pools
that cleanses them and that's how we
clean off our sacrifices before we
sacrifice them what what's up
here okay mark
now we
[Music]
[Music]
i really care about it
bob you keep scaring me
i'm just a guy in a gothic outfit
walking around what's scary about you
look at someone from good charlotte you
wanna go swimming
where are you
[Music]
hey guys i'm stuck oh i fixed it
i'm washing myself
please oh is it like a bath house i'm
washing myself every time
my does my flashlight run out are we all
here are we all here yeah wow why are
you singing like that
ah the the bathwater the bathroom
wait i was just hitting the bathroom are
you guys in the bath okay i'll come back
to the bath
i'm getting back cool [ __ ] over here i
think you're in a different bath i'm in
a bath but no one else is in the bath
where's your bath you're in an actual
bath come out and go right over here oh
hey what's up dogs
all right uh i'm going to lead you all
to the way of pain
what why
i don't want to go there
should i like
donate to bite down on something yeah
you should donate to me and then you can
bite down on something that sounds good
no one said anything about donating but
uh i'll bite i heard what i wanted to
hear i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking let's wait he never knows what
he's talking about all right that's true
what if we just like so fast
yeah oh bob you're so good oh yeah no
all right you ready for more voice
acting yeah yeah all right well it's
complete i feel my fault shifting
incredible pain this is not how it is
supposed to be i did everything right i
was supposed to have control i could
hear the sound of his laughter in my
mind slow and hollow
are you doing a german accent it's
always just out of reach like a moving
echo that was uh
yeah that's how i talk wow is that the
cincinnati accent
from cincinnati would be kind of german
there's a lady here oh
um
egg must be cleansed
[Applause]
from spiders
every egg has a symbol yeah what about
it
when you clean it you'll see what symbol
it is and that's the altar you have to
take it yeah what of it what of it
there's a symbol what of it
what's this what is it what is it
is it the style cause i don't find it
convenient i'm cleaning it oh how do you
do that wade right oh right mouse button
got it got it we're on normal difficulty
where we have a full nice purple bar on
our flashlight at the top right when you
get the hardest difficulty you get zero
flashlight so you can't get rid of those
enemies unless you find batteries which
are very scary it's got a fire a fire
nation symbol well
the one we were just at the circle so
that's not it yeah it's like this is
inside this building
are we giving you hopeful information
the extreme
um so
it's not here now that we've started it
now keys have spawned we need to find
keys to unlock more doors oh well that
was obvious you're a good chief tell me
that
you're welcome i'm here to help
you like that one
yeah i
like slam the door in my face oh if
you're a key you don't unlock it
i'm not a key i'm a man
manky
i found another egg there's another egg
here
oh he picked up the room a key such a
key oh bro i have no idea where roommate
is i've not played this map in so long
oh i'm buying roommates i'm actually if
you go upstairs um roommate is buying
this egg as well yeah
wait turn around up here
so there's an egg here and then there's
roommate right there
okay
and then roommate oh my god
what where's the we're great
okay
oh i totally knew how to do that i saved
you wayne oh it's thank you
uh uh uh altar
[Music]
all of those asteroids huh
guys i got the round recorder i mean
pretty much what what you got
hourglasses that you want to defend you
say not
i never watched it i don't think of that
at all but here it was great what a key
what key
must be the next one down i thought you
opened room five oh you're wasting
precious egg cleansing time guys i got
room 4k where's four four four four
right here
right next to it four four four here
four here
four
hey look it's it's a penis
room oh yeah that too hey the mind sees
what it wants to see i thought it was a
sword fire
okay
i got room five key guys oh we need
those batteries i'll show you room five
i watched i seen it
do it
i did it
the egg all right now we've officially
started and pissed everybody off cool
why do we have why do we have cabbages
who got the hole
whoa what
that's about that's very bad that's good
uh room five is over here bob
i'm hiding in a closet i'm not coming
over there get out of here come on
where are they
holy the [ __ ] that's not good
[Music]
how do we kill her
[Applause]
[Music]
hey mark did you get his egg yeah i got
his egg okay guys oh she's still here
all right
oh i'm in tiny baby jail well that's
really something
oh i found the light i'm out oh i'm in
the cave
how do you get clean
water which is the cave we gotta find
those little bottles of sprite oh
i saw i have one i have one okay and i'm
gonna clean it we've got room to hold
this egg so i can go revive our friend
there's another egg down here nobody
takes it i'm still upstairs is that good
the spiders can steal your eggs if you
drop them by the way spiders steal well
why did you drop this egg so i could go
revive our friend but i have an egg
there's an egg another egg here guard it
with your life you got a flashlight i
don't think i'm gonna do that actually
if you it's the
second you didn't tell me oh nozakis
i figured maybe you'd want to guard it
if you do oh thank you sweetheart save
your colors to show i mean i took it and
i ran with it the penis uh the penis one
is um
now undergarden is honest of course
absolutely where's room five i just
wanted to find room five upstairs right
next to room four i am upstairs
looking for the i found it
i found it guys there's a big five on it
bob do you see the units honest one
and six
oh the goat one
one is in here in room five goat
go
it was room eight so there is a strategy
to make this easier but you know i'm not
going to tell you all about that the
first time
i'm doing fine without you what are you
doing i'm talking about you know without
me i have been a [ __ ] egg
everything
is on its own yes honestly
[Laughter]
hey what do i what do i do hey i have an
egg what do i do with that oh you wash
it if it's dirty
yeah bring it to the spot follow me
oh not that way you you don't want to go
that way no not again not again
hey you following me
buddy don't worry all right good i'm
right behind you there's an airplane
i'm holding it you got a spider okay
okay
put the egg in there i'm gonna wash out
this pool hey mark i'm hearing like
spidery noises no no no no good no no no
hey
the water it says the eggs can only be
cleaned in clean water and right now
it's not letting
those not clean anymore
i don't know man
hum shut up
wait where's the other one oh is it over
here yeah bottom one yeah that's all i
got i'll try to find another cleansy
that doesn't sound good
i'm afraid i'm about to be spider
grabbed no no no no no no
whoo
i feel like i'm about to be
spider-grabbed
is she up here i don't know how do i
look at what egg what is on my egg i
don't see her up here right now when
it's clean you should be able to see it
or in the symbol
top left
oh this is going to be i don't know
where goat is yeah
oh hey i found her
am i about to be grabbed christ that's
so loud oh wait where do i revive you
hey a goat where's goat where's goat one
i had goat egg on me it's on the floor
right now that was so loud guys yeah but
where's goat altar
five froome five i believe was goat
alternate up here
i'm biting
currently
she's standing on an egg right now hey
what's up
if you come upstairs yeah what's up
hey
i got it
all right i'm going to take some water
down and clean up yeah guys
i'm like the mvp of this game this is
like the third one i've slammed home i'm
good at this i'm pretty good at this
you're so freaking good
thank you
oh you pissed again she's no longer calm
it's just me
hey protect me guys
i'm doing the eggs so you got to protect
me guys where am i who am i
spider lady yeah
spider lady
how do we kill her
you can't you can just stun her okay oh
[ __ ]
later later
see you around the bend guys
did she get are you dead
because i was stunning her and then
everyone left and then i was just alone
that's okay they're standing in your egg
ah well that's not good
i got it i got an egg oh man that was
close guys i'm going to be back
for you well thank you there's a spider
right by me in the bathroom watch out
there was crucifix upside down
thing or stairs i think
oh gosh
uh i don't think this is a good time
gotta be honest yeah no this seems fine
wait wait it's not fine wade
i i you viewed her it didn't seem to do
it oh criminy shits
jesus christ that's loud
it's so loud
and also i don't know what i just uv the
entire room and those spiders didn't
give a hot diggity [ __ ] about it
she's puking up an egg right now oh oh
she gets the eggs ah
hey i'm coming to save you guys i think
if you just revive wade and then walk
away from me
i need to make it there's a whole [ __ ]
there's a whole streets on the spiders
over here waiting careful
mine like two of them on me
hey guys i i think i hear [ __ ] i think
she might
everywhere i need to stop dying that's
what i need to do hmm yeah you hear that
i think it's america
watch out she's uh
[Laughter]
anyway all right uh i'm just gonna hide
in the closet for a second so i cannot
die for like five seconds i hate this
lady whoa wait watch out there's spiders
oh there's one behind me she's right
here right here
wait no hey cool give me egg i got it
wait where's that okay you got it okay
i have one just turn around
it's not in here
it's okay it's okay it happens man it
happens
hey what are you doing on the floor wait
mark my sword is right here i'm not a
liar i'm a liar liar we're gonna find
him is
mar
yeah it's in here it's in here i'm gonna
close this door where is it in here i
can't i can't it's the sword what do you
mean the weirdest thing is an upside
down cross
what is a sword then it looks like a
sword not a cross that looks like a
sword to me
i'm sorry
hey whoa
my friend
oh shoot wow he did not
give a [ __ ] hey this uh this spider's
got an egg down here that's the sound of
a spider that's gonna kill me probably
hey what's up we need a little kids they
don't have the room 2 keys room 2 key
not yet
i think i have it why do you oh you're
good
behind you
oh that's probably not good
no don't get them they have so much to
live for yeah i don't see a med kit
anywhere somebody on me oh there's
makeup i'm a oh
my god
there's two med kits here for when you
need to revive mark that's quite loud
you you have a medkit on you here
somewhere literally right in my face
i feel like a med kid
that turned into water are you jesus i
am reversed oh [ __ ] i got the egg for
the cave
the cave egg hello
don't worry i'll distract them
i'm cleaning the water guys hey nice man
okay i am leaving boy that sounds loud
and close yep i am leaving you gotta
wait if i just if i just close the door
can they not come in here if i close the
door she's like son of a [ __ ] uh you
want to crawl out of the cave and help
me oh yeah
she always sounds closer than she is yes
she does and it's
[ __ ] dude
dude i don't know where i died with the
sword egg but i had it
there's a passport now somewhere
all right well that's fine oh
i got a sword egg guys hey
hey that's what a sword looks like
admittedly a little upside down crossy
oh
it looks kind of like an upside down
cross i can't lie but i mean
[Laughter]
she came around the corner and i was
like
didn't do nothing yeah she does that i'm
just building up a resistance i'm having
no luck with med kids wait where's
get out of the cave
is room two downstairs
upstairs so you can use on someone else
or whatever yeah wait uh if you could uh
chop chop hurry up
come on wait
is this fine too i might have found room
too i'm sure guys are gonna laugh
there's there's make kids down here huh
oh [ __ ] please be stunned please be
stunned oh [ __ ]
all right are we faced with news bad
news good news she was stunned bad news
she found me uh-huh and there's a main
kit right here hey found him yeah i got
i got a med kit wayne i've got one i
just need to get to you [ __ ]
hello it's in the storage room which is
apparently a lot don't speak ill of the
dead oh thank you
yeah you're welcome
all right you're up thank you you're
welcome
everybody gets one you're welcome how
many of you like it because i've
definitely burned my one already more
than one
kid over this way whoever's over here
where i don't know the corner i don't
know it's like right here through this
wall or something where
i can see it through this wall it's in
the other room
yeah oh it's open
are you got that okay yeah i opened it
close the door
big big incoming big incoming you guys
might want to run in three two now run
run away yeah i can't where
hey wade how you doing i'm pretty good
i'm just looking for room two
yeah me too bob you said you found room
two where is it i i was dead man i don't
know i found i found a storage room
still two left yeah but it's fine
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no no no no no
no it's okay
oh son of a [ __ ] did you get god oh
she's right there near me oh she truly
is
[Music]
truly and justly she is right there
verily so indeed
honestly
i must go now oh my people need me
oh i closed the door is that going to
keep her away from me no yeah uh 100
yeah okay good but it seems to have
worked guys we just need to be closing
doors that's all we need to be doing
right now i found the storage room and
there's two eggs there's two eggs in the
storage room one a spider has one of
them and the other is vomited on the
floor all right i'm gonna try to revive
somebody whoever's up here yeah i have a
med kit i uh with ways to get in the
upstairs i'll wait for whoever else is
down to get out of the butthole caves
there are so many spiders yeah you might
want to be careful with
suck up you die oh [ __ ] look right
behind you man there's i don't have i
don't have i don't have i don't have any
battery sounds like he doesn't have any
batteries uh yeah so you guys just um
i'm chilling down but me
what is there boss music playing no
wait's the life yeah we're still alive
oh i'm alive hey what's up dude
hey you got a spider on you there buddy
yeah i'm looking for medkits have you
seen any oh [ __ ] [ __ ] she was behind
me
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh that doesn't sound good oh oh oh
oh no
probably not a good idea to stay here
but uh no i'll get you i got you okay
thanks man worrying about it
storage room key or something coming up
you got it guys if i'm honest
i do yeah i do wear this one yeah uh you
got the storage room
he's a friend he's a friend oh that's
not good
that'd be great we don't like the sounds
that i'm hearing
this is
hey mark did my warnings help you key i
got no key yeah thanks i have a storage
i have the storage room key uh open it
up the two eggs are in there
up here by the down people up on the
balcony area yeah i don't have any
battery for my lady
oh there's so many there's a bunch of
other oh hey buddy seems like you guys
are down uh
yeah but there's medkits here oh cool
there's a medkit in the storage room i
hate to tell you guys but all four of us
[Laughter]
we've all been down for a while
wiggle guys wiggles
for the occasion
all right
oh
oh
you get it now we get developed yeah
well good game guys good good job
you